welcome to america the freest country in
the entire world which we know is true
because it's a thing that people say and
you might actually believe that until
you try to build housing somewhere or
drink alcohol in public but
unfortunately america is not the freest
country in the world in fact according
to some it's barely in the top 20 freest
countries but the world is a diverse
place and one country's freedom is
another country's criminal violation and
there are wide swaths of activities that
are perfectly normal in other countries
but also very very illegal in america so
today let's look at some international
liberties that could get you fined or
locked up if you tried them stateside
and some of these foreign freedoms may
surprise you but let's start with a
truly evil and dastardly product one
that actually specifically targets
children i'm of course talking about
kinder eggs now we like to say that
children are the future and here in
america the moment we find out that
something puts children in danger
legislators pull out all the stops to
ensure that we try to keep our kids safe
and that's why america has stood firm to
cracking down on a grave and terrible
threat to children's health and safety
posed by toy-filled chocolate eggs
kinder surprise eggs which famously
contain a yellow capsule
which contains a small toy have been a
beloved staple for children around the
world ever since the product's
introduction in 1974 by ferrero an
italian company but in the united states
these toy-filled treats have been
classified as dangerous illegal
contraband and some background in 1938
the u.s passed the food drug and
cosmetic act which empowered government
agencies to regulate food safety and
under consumer safety regulations issued
by the fda and the consumer product
safety commission the sale and
distribution of any food with a quote
non-nutritive object embedded is
prohibited and that includes toys found
inside confectionary items now although
you can find kinder surprise eggs in
canada and mexico don't try to bring
them into this country or you risk
serious fines in 2011 the u.s customs
and border protection the cbp seized
more than 60 000 kinder eggs from
travelers baggage and international mail
shipments more than twice that number
from 2010. this caused the cbp to issue
a press release in 2012 warning people
to try to stop sneaking chocolate eggs
into the country quote also known as
kinder eggs these chocolate treats may
be cute and seasonal but they are too
dangerous to children to be imported
legally into the u.s the problem is the
small plastic toy inside the kinder egg
while sold in many countries this
product is banned from the us because
young children can choke on it now some
people have argued that these kinder
eggs are not a risk to european children
and canadian children because european
and canadian children are smarter than
us
children
now a few months after the cbp released
that statement a married couple from
seattle was detained at the canadian
border when the pair was caught with six
kinder eggs from vancouver the couple
was unaware that they were in possession
of illegal ovarian contraband and was
even more shocked that each egg carried
a penalty of 2500 dollars per egg now
luckily for that couple they were let
off with a warning but not to worry
american kinder fans because in 2018
ferrero introduced a modified kinder joy
egg that complies with us regulations
crucially the kinder joy is not actually
an egg-shaped chocolate it's half a
chocolate egg with wafer bits inside
while the toy is kept on the other side
of the egg away from the edible bit
which i guess is suitable for hapless
american children and despite the fear
surrounding kinder eggs there's little
evidence that these chocolate delights
are as dangerous as claimed now there
have been seven reported child deaths
between 1989 and 2016 a relatively tiny
number in the face of billions of eggs
sold and furthermore the packaging warns
parents that the eggs are not suitable
for kids under the age of three and
supervision is recommended but let's not
leave food-based illegality because
while americans remain deeply divided on
a wide variety of issues there's one
thing that most of us can agree on and
that's that life begins at cheese now
over the last 40 years our love of
cheese much like our waistbands has
grown between 1977 and 2020 we americans
have increased our annual cheese
consumption from 16 pounds to 40 pounds
every year and i'm probably responsible
for about half of that so needless to
say we americans love our cheese whether
it's on pizza burgers or in the form of
64 jesus infused slices of american
cheese have you been up all night eating
cheese i think i'm blind but if you're
taking a cheese tour of the world be
careful what you bring back to the
united states because your love of
cheese might just put you in legal
jeopardy you guys enjoying that cheese
it's unpasteurized it's illegal in this
country in fact many raw soft cheeses
from france like blue dejects rogueford
or red blue shawn are illegal in the
united states due to the fda's strict
cheese production regulations under
these rules cheeses made with raw
unpasteurized milk is illegal to import
or sell in the united states unless it
has been aged for at least 60 days the
reasoning is of course food safety
namely to minimize the risk of foodborne
contagions like listeria salmonella and
e coli and after 60 days the acids and
salts in raw milk cheese coupled with
the aging process begin to naturally
kill these types of harmful bacteria but
here's the thing
anyone who has ever been to france knows
that the cheese is so so much better
there and it's not just raw cheese the
fda has also cracked out on certain
cheeses just because they contain
too many live insects that's the case
with kazoo matsu a traditional sardinian
sheep's milk cheese that's intentionally
infested with live maggots kazumatu
which literally means rotten cheese gets
its special flavor from being left to
rot out among swarms of fly larvae and
while i'm told this hellish looking
cheese is actually quite delicious it
turns out that eating maggots is
actually a tremendous health risk
earning the cheese the nickname the
world's most dangerous cheese and as a
result kazumatsu is not only illegal in
the us but in the entire european union
but here's the thing anyone who has ever
been to sardinia knows the maggot-filled
cheese is just so much better there but
the french have also been on the
receiving end of big government's
anti-bug-eating crusade in 2013 the fda
angered american chisophiles by blocking
the import of french mimolet cheese just
because the cheese is naturally infested
with cheese mites and while most cheese
makers consider the mites a nuisance
mimolet producers actually encourage the
microscopic critters to burrow into the
rind in order to help the cheese ripen
and produce its distinctively sweet
earthy flavor
mighty
but the fda has determined that eating
too many mites could cause an allergic
reaction resulting in the ban of the
gouda-like cheese and though the fda has
no legal limit on cheese mites the
agency indicated a target of no more
than six mites per square inch which
marmalade simply cannot meet so what are
the consequences of contraband cheese we
got a tip about some food entering the
country illegally
no no no no no no well the failure to
declare food products on your customs
forms can result in fines of up to ten
thousand dollars and your unlawful
cheese will be seized but be forewarned
there is a thriving black market for
cheese in the united states and illegal
cheese is very much on the government's
radar the department of homeland
security you know the post-911 agency
responsible for protecting the country
from terrorism and kinder eggs has
helped bust cheese smuggling rings into
canada but unless you're a large-scale
cheese smuggler you're probably not
looking at any jail time wow
you got me good one making me think i
was gonna like die in federal prison ah
that's super funny you scamps so worst
case scenario you're probably looking at
a fine and suffering the on way of
eating your dry cheeseless crackers
alone
but let's leave the food world and get
into something that probably makes a
little bit more sense now a source of
pride for the baby boomer generation is
that everything was dangerous and no one
seemed to care
yes that golden area where we lined our
walls with cancerous asbestos medical
professionals smoked in hospitals and
people sold chemistry sets to children
that contained real uranium so of course
as a society we used to let kids hurl
giant darts into the air with impunity
and call it a national pastime that's
the story of lawn darts which have been
illegal in the united states since 1988
after being linked to thousands of
injuries and the deaths of at least
three children lawn darts known as
javelin darts or jarts was a popular
lawn game in the mid 20th century
gameplay was actually quite
straightforward players would take turns
tossing giant darts into a circle place
about 35 feet away all a cornhole but
with giant razor-sharp darts raining
down from the sky instead of soft bean
bags now unfortunately throwing a giant
metal dart is a tremendous safety hazard
and government regulators eventually
began to take notice this isn't child's
play according to the food and drug
administration the us's first attempt to
outlaw the game was strenuously posed by
dirt manufacturers who fought the
proposed fda ban in court in 1970
manufacturers actually won a compromise
that would allow the sale of lawn darts
so long as it was one only marketed to
adults then two the product was no
longer sold in toy stores and three the
product contained warning labels
alerting consumers to keep it out of the
reach of children but unfortunately
these compromise measures were
insufficient to prevent tragedy for
aerospace engineer david snow in april
1987 snow's seven-year-old daughter
michelle was killed by a lawn dart
thrown by one of her nine-year-old
brothers playmates in the backyard of
their home in riverside california the
dart hit her head with approximately 23
000 pounds of pressure per square inch
and snow's daughter died three days
later the grieving father then made it
his mission to lobby public officials to
take lawn darts off the market for good
snow brought his complaint to the
consumer product safety commission who
were persuaded to investigate snow's
claims the commission discovered that
over a period of eight years lawn darts
had sent six thousand one hundred people
to the emergency room eighty-one percent
of those cases involved kids aged 15 or
younger half were 10 or younger and many
had suffered permanent injury disability
or even death in 1988 snow prevailed in
his crusade the commission voted 2-1 to
prohibit the sale of all lawn darts and
had them removed from stores in time for
that year's christmas and canada also
outlawed lawn darts in july of 1989. now
if you want to play traditional lawn
darts you'll have to hop on a plane and
visit the european union where the game
is still legal but here in the us you
can find a legal version with a modified
plastic blunt tip that replaces the
sharp metal tip
because that makes quite a lot more
sense but that takes us to something
that's arguably even more dangerous
smoking now for most of the 20th century
cigarette smoking was glorified as the
ultimate embodiment of the american west
things like tough guys rebels without a
cause in advertising doctors endorse
their favorite brands while we were told
that women found smoking men
irresistible but this image of health
and sex appeal slowly began to change
starting in 1964 after the us surgeon
general stated definitively that yes
smoking tobacco can be fatal and
research shows that flavored cigarettes
largely appeal to and are
disproportionately used by those under
18 years of age that is not how to
inhale bobby you're hot boxing it so to
help combat youth smoking in 2009 the
fda banned the sale of flavored
cigarettes including cloves cinnamon
candy and fruit flavors pursuant to the
family smoking prevention and control
act though menthol cigarettes were
exempted from the ban as well as
non-cigarette tobacco products like
electronic cigarettes cigars smokeless
tobacco and hookah but the us is not
alone here as countries with policies
banning some or all types of flavored
cigarettes include canada brazil
ethiopia uganda senegal niger mauritania
and 28 member states of the european
union moldova turkey and singapore as
for everyone else well not only are
flavored cigarettes completely legal in
the vast majority of countries but the
u.s ban on cloves actually created an
international incident in april 2010
indonesia the world's top producer of
clove cigarettes and the source of the
vast majority of those smoked in the u.s
filed a trade dispute with a world trade
organization in its claim indonesia
argued that the us ban illegally
discriminated against foreign products
of flavored tobacco and created an
unlawful advantage for domestic tobacco
manufacturers in september 2011 the w2o
agreed finding that the ban was indeed
discriminatory because it prohibited
clove cigarettes while allowing the sale
of american menthol cigarettes the
opinion was affirmed on appeal in 2012.
this ruling gave indonesia the right to
retaliate until either the u.s changed
its law to comply or the two sides
reached a settlement and in 2014 the two
countries reached a final settlement on
the issue ending their dispute under the
settlement the us agreed it would not
arbitrarily discriminate against certain
indonesian tobacco products and promised
to work with indonesia on other trade
issues now a decade after the flavored
tobacco ban public health advocates seem
to have been vindicated a 2020 study
published in the journal of adolescent
health found that the flavor ban was
effective at reducing cigarette use
among young people in april of 2022 the
fda took additional steps against
flavored tobacco products by proposing a
ban on the sales of menthol cigarettes
and all flavored cigars in his proposal
the fda argued that these actions had
the potential to reduce disease and
death by reducing youth experimentation
and addiction and increasing the number
of smokers that quit public comments
will continue through july of 2022 but
kinder surprise eggs are already banned
so the hard work has already been
accomplished but that takes us to the
next american illegality something you
potentially might do every single day
now if you were an american pedestrian
in 1903 crossing the street was a very
simple endeavor if you wanted to cross
the street you would just walk across
the street before the introduction of
cars roads were seen as a public space
that all citizens had a right to occupy
even children at play but today if you
try and cross the street without using a
crosswalk or cross the street when the
traffic light is flashing do not walk
well congratulations you have committed
the crime
of jaywalking now across the pond some
of our european allies have taken a more
laissez-faire attitude towards
jaywalking by making it totally legal
they just call it
walking now for example there are no
laws against jaywalking in norway the
same goes for the uk meaning that the
beatles didn't need to use the crosswalk
for their famous abbey road cover and
the netherlands used to have laws
against jaywalking but repealed these
statues in 1995 to simplify the traffic
code and give pedestrians more freedom
in these countries your right to cross
the street freely shall not be infringed
but here in the united states we've
taken a more punitive approach to
walking now every year cities like los
angeles issue tickets to tens of
thousands of pedestrians for jaywalking
which includes fines worth up to 200
but this was not always the case in fact
ticketing someone for jaywalking is a
relatively young concept in the united
states according to university of
virginia historian peter norton the
notion of jaywalking with jay being an
early 20th century slur for someone
stupid or unsophisticated was introduced
by a group of auto industry aligned
groups in the 1920s as part of a
concerted pro-car anti-pedestrian
propaganda campaign but when cars were
first introduced there were a few
crosswalks painted on the street
pedestrians generally ignored the ones
that existed because they didn't need to
but as cars became more widely available
pedestrian deaths skyrocketed with
hundreds of thousands of americans many
children being killed in car crashes for
the first few decades of the 20th
century so to counter all this negative
publicity auto industries sought to
enact traffic laws that would shift
blame from drivers and their cars
to the pedestrians themselves and it
worked not only did cities and states
begin criminalizing jaywalking but the
us government supported the
anti-pedestrian propaganda campaign by
ridiculing jaywalkers and placing blame
on them for automobile crashes and today
some criminal justice advocates believe
jaywalking should be decriminalized
altogether but as an aside you should
all go watch not just bikes and get
orange build because it's kind of stupid
that we've seeded all of this real
estate to cars for both driving and
parking when cities should be for the
people themselves but i'll get down off
of my soapbox and while it might sound
counterintuitive countries that allow
jaywalking tend to have lower traffic
deaths as pedestrians tend to cross more
safely and when they aren't worried
about criminal penalties and criminal
justice advocates point out that
jaywalking laws have a very disparate
impact with tickets not evenly applied
and enforcement disproportionately
targeting people of color so far in 2021
virginia has heeded this call by
becoming the first and so far only state
to decriminalize jaywalking and a
similar bill to decriminalize jaywalking
was vetoed by california's governor
gavin newsom in 2021. so for better or
worse if you want to stay on the
straight and narrow in 49 of the u.s
states you'd better be sure to look both
ways and stay in the crosswalk every
time for now okay so maybe america isn't
the freest country in the world after
all but you can take a stand for your
right to exclusive content with today's
sponsors nebula and curiosity stream on
nebula my videos always come out early
and with zero ads and i release
exclusive content all the time like a
video on the things that people
misunderstand about the constitution why
nfcs are bad for creators anti-slap laws
my first full-length documentary bad law
words good and tons more all exclusive
to nebula it's truly the rarest kinder
egg and my friends post exclusive
content to nebula all the time as well
like real engineering's entire d-day
series and half as interesting's crime
spree where they try to break as many
silly laws across the u.s as possible
all of this exclusive content is
available only on nebula which you get
for free with curiosity stream because
nebula is creator owned and creator
operated and by the way we've been
developing nebula like crazy nebula now
has apps for ios android apple tv roku
fire tv android tv and it was recently
nominated for its first streamy award
and my fellow creators and i really care
about nebula and we're thrilled to be
partnering with curiositystream because
they are the go-to source for the best
documentaries in long-form educational
content on the internet and they even
have an entire section devoted to
unsolved mysteries and crime so if you
like my videos you'll love the thousands
of titles on curiosity stream and the
best way to get access to nebula and all
the incredible content is through the
amazing curiosity stream nebula bundle
deal with its current sales price of
less than 15 a year to get full access
to both sites and to be clear that
nebulous subscription is not a trial
it's free for as long as you're a
curiosity stream member there just isn't
a better deal in streaming where you get
two great streaming sites with content
you'll actually watch and enjoy for less
than 15 a year at the current sales
price but what's more signing up will
actually help countless independent
educational creators beyond just legal
eagle so sign up now by clicking on this
button that's on screen right now or you
can click on the link that's down below
in the description it's a great way to
support educational content and get tons
of exclusive content that you'll love so
click on these links right now or you
can click on this playlist over here
with all my other youtube videos so
click on this link or i'll see you in
court